I know it's not a challenge charlie
video alright I've I've been busy I
think that you I've been busy
Charlie it's so Charlie yes so Tommy is
so cool okay hello everybody
alright I'm here today to tell you that
I have got some good news it seems that
I have been selected to do an interview
Hiyori oh my god he's gonna be doing
another interview with charlie is so
cool like what what are you talking
about wait a grilling gorila is back and
he's gonna be doing another interview
with charlie is so cool no no I'm gonna
be I'm really doing a talk with Dane I'm
not gonna be doing another interview
with you I took you out of my videos
remember I can't have you in them
anymore
yo you're just too racist our knife is a
racist dude you're a gorilla with a
Jamaican accent it's a bit racist so yes
like I was saying I'm going to be doing
a talk with Dave there's a guy here on
YouTube from the UK called Davey boys
and I'm going to be doing an interview
with him so yeah basically I say
basically way too much
basically what I'm suggesting basically
all you would need to do is basically
like basically what I did basically the
reason I'm making this video is because
Dave needs questions to ask me
unfortunately I have 30,000 very very
smart and cool people who will be very
good at coming up with creative
questions to ask me so if you have a
question you want to ask me post a
comment below and if you want to watch
the video then go and subscribe to Davey
boys so you don't miss it okay the
reason I haven't posted a challenge
charlie video yet is because I'm going
to be doing a rap and I'm putting it off
because I don't really want to do it but
I'm gonna do it okay I promise bye